[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now time to
talk all things
spring lifestyle expert don mccarthy
fills us in
hi las vegas now it's spring and i have
four great products you should add to
your daily routine
first exercise and i have just the brand
to get you out there moving in vegas
style with lights
it's also award season with hollywood's
biggest night approaching
and i actually picked up this first
product at one of the gifting lounges
and suites
introducing ghost longboards which is a
family-friendly company
that takes pride in making amazing
longboards
out of their facility in utah these
ghost boards ship
around the world and they love to help
create custom
board designs with your name your logo
or
anything that you can think of look how
cool this one is for las vegas
and yes it lights up just like the city
they are easy to ride fun unique
affordable so check out
ghostlongboard.com
to get one today now at one point or
another
you will be sleep deprived you might
even have a hangover in vegas
or will just be generally exhausted and
run down
so make sure you have it's a secret
eye gel pads ready these pads help to
reduce puffiness
dryness fine lines and dark circles all
with a hint of
sparkle to keep it fun or they come in
black too jc and kendall
which the guys like to wear or i wear
under my eyes on game day
these are exactly what you need to look
refreshed for selfies
facetimes and those zoom calls and my
little secret i actually put them in the
refrigerator
and use them on my frown lines too go to
sh
dash online to get a pair and what i
also love about spring is cocktails
and i'm making it easy for you to choose
with my go-to
stellarosawines.com stellarosa is the
number one
imported wine brand in the united states
and america's favorite
semi-sweet semi-sparkling italian wine
made with real fruit flavor so it's best
to be consumed within three days of
opening
they're naturally gluten free and vegan
low calorie
and low alcohol making them the perfect
wine at any time of day or night
they even have a great selection of
non-alcoholic choices as well
all under 15 too you can find all of
these wines and over a hundred amazing
stella rosa cocktails
on their website and don't forget to
serve them chilled
now do you love food because i know i do
well you can thank me later after trying
this new vegan
plant-based pancake and waffle mix from
bushwick
kitchen it was just launched so you're
seeing it here first
and available at walmart stores
nationwide you can now elevate your
breakfast game like a chef or i admit to
having
breakfast for dinner sometimes too this
mix is made with organic ingredients
like oat milk and whole grains
and the pancake mixes are infused with
bold flavors like
cinnamon and habanero peppers to take
ordinary pancakes and syrup to a whole
new level
go to any walmart today to pick them up
so
have a great spring time in las vegas
and go to my website dawnscorner.com
if you need more information on any of
these products i feature here today
thank you don for more information you
can go to donscorner.com